اعلنت وزاره الصحه في قطاع غزه ان قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ارتكبت في الساعات ال
24 الماضيه 4 مجزره في حق الاهالي بقطاع
غزه ادت الى استشهاد
215 شخصا وقال مراسل الجزيره ان قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي نفذت سلسله غارات
ونسفت مربعات سكنيه في خانيونس ضمن حملتها
العسكريه على المحافظه مراسل الجزيره
اسماعيل ابو عمر يرصد لنا قرب طبيعه
الاوضاع في تلك
المنطقه ما زالت الانفجارات تتوالى بين
الحين وال الاخر في ظل استمرار العمليه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه في محافظه خانيونس
والانفجارات هذه تتركز في الاجزاء الغربيه
وكذلك في وسط محافظه خان يونس كما تشاهدون
في الصوره اعمده الدخان تتصاعد بين الحين
والاخر نتيجه هذه الغارات التي تنفذها
طائرات الاحتلال الى جانب ما تقوم به قوات
الاحتلال من عمليات نسف جديده لمربعات
سكنيه بشكل كبير جدا وهو ما يميز الساعه
الماضيه من عمليات النسف التي تقوم بها
قوات الاحتلال في اكثر من محور من محاور
تواجدها في منطقه خان يونس تحديدا في وسط
البلد وكذلك في منطقه معسكر خان يونس
اضافه الى منطقه حي الامل غارات عديده
نفذتها طائرات الاحتلال خلال الساعات
الماضيه وتركزت كما تحدثنا ايضا في
الاجزاء الغربيه للمحافظه الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني تحدث بان قوات الاحتلال ما زالت
تحاصر مستشفى الامل في منطقه المشروع
وهناك عدد من الجرحى والشهداء وصلوا الى
المستشفى حيث ان قوات الاحتلال تحاصر هذا
المستشفى ومنعت المواطنين من الوصول لبعض
الاصابات الموجوده في محيط مستشفى الامل
واطلقت النار باتجاههم ما ادى الى ارتقاء
ثلاثه شهداء تم نقلهم الى مستشفى الامل في
حين ان هناك مخاوف شديده على حياه عديد
المواطنين المتواجدين في محيط مستشفى
الامل خاصه ممن يرغبون النزوح الى هذا
المستشفى مستشف باعتباره باعتباره مستشفى
او مكان امن يمكن اللجوء اليه لكن قوات
الاحتلال ايضا لا تتوانى عن استهداف هذا
المستشفى بين الحين والاخر طلقات ناريه
تستهدف هذا المستشفى الى جانب غارات وكذلك
قذائف مدفعيه تطلقها في محيط مستشفى الامل
في محافظه خان يونس هناك عدد من الشهداء
ما زالت جثامينهم ملقاه على الارض في
الطرقات ايضا سواء في منطقه معسكر خانيونس
وكذلك في منطقه حي الامل اضافه الى
المناطق الشرقيه للمحافظه وي صعب على
الطواقم الاسعاف نقل هذه الجثامين الى
مستشفيات خانيونس كما اننا نتحدث بان هذه
المستشفيات من اصلها ايضا محاصره باليات
الاحتلال فيسلك المواطنون طرق التفاف لنقل
بعض الاصابات من اجل نقلها الى منطقه
المواصي وتحديدا الى منطقه ايضا نقطه طبيه
في المواصي ومن هناك يتم نقل هذه الاصابات
والشهداء الى مستشفيات سواء في في رفح او
حتى مستشفى غز الاوروبي في اقصى الجنوب
الشرقي لمحافظه خانيونس c